but uh your book can mortality what
what's the story
that you tell in this book
what do you which part of human history
are you studying
right so that's that's the way to phrase
it so it's you know it's my 12-year
search
for the hard scientific data
for the ritual use of psychedelics and
classical antiquity so we're talking
about amongst the ancient greeks and
romans
and the paleo christians uh so the
generations that would give birth to the
largest religion the world's ever known
christianity today was two and a half
billion people the big question for me
is you know were psychedelics actually
involved there was a lot written about
this in the 60s john marco allegro
the book that i follow was published in
1978 before i was born the road to
ellucis
by gordon watson who we talked about
already albert hofmann who famously
discovers lsd or synthesizes it from
ergot and karl ruck
who is still a professor of classics at
boston university the only surviving
member of that renegade trio and now 85
years old so this this all predates us
um but what was lacking in the 60s 70s
80s 90s i think was some of this
technology
and and the hard scientific data now for
years and years i went out to the
archaeobotanists and the archaeochemists
around the world and i asked a very
basic question is there any evidence
for psychedelics and classical antiquity
and the answer would almost invariably
come back no i'm talking to in addition
to pat he put me in touch with hans
peter stika in germany tania valamotti
in greece a sunta florenzano in italy i
went all over the place asking one
question and getting the same answer
back time and again and so the book is
essentially my my search for that data
and the eventual uncovering of two what
i think are key pieces of data one data
one data point
shows the ritual use of a psychedelic
beer
in classical antiquity in iberia with
today's spain and the other shows what
looks like a kind of psychedelic wine
just outside pompeii from the 1st
century
a.d at the right place at the right time
when the earliest christians were
showing up in italy
again these are early steps in the
search for evidence in this space but
uh speaking of early christians
what role do you think
psychedelic infused wine could have
played
in the life of
the
i i won't be clever in the life of jesus
christ
i've been saying recently that and i
hope this doesn't sound
obscurantist but i think it's impossible
to understand jesus and the birth of
christianity in the absence of ancient
greek and i'll give you a very specific
example of why i think that's the case
you can read the entire new testament
in ancient greek and not once will you
ever find a reference to alcohol
because there was no word in ancient
greek for alcohol the way the word
sounds alcohol it comes it's semitic it
comes from the arabic
khala means to enliven a refresh it
probably comes from coal kohl sort of
these powdered metallics that were used
in alchemical experiments in cosmetics
so again that's much later in time
when we're using alchemy distillation
etc in the first century ad
the power of wine wasn't necessarily
tied to alcohol right fermented grapes
the way we think about wine today so pat
mcgovern found some of that early
organic data for wine being mixed
with
with beer and with mead but if you look
at the literature from the first century
a.d diocerities for example he writes
this this massive treatise at the exact
same time the gospels are being written
and diascorides
in just one of his books talks about 56
detailed recipes
for spiking wine with all kinds of
things like salvia and hellebore and
frankincense and myrrh these spiced
perfumes but also more dangerous things
like henbane and mandrake which he says
in greek can be fatal with just one
cupful and in book 474 of his materia
medica
he talks about black nightshade
producing fantasias
not unpleasant visions
what today we would say is psychedelic
so just looking at the literature and
the kind of literature that even most
classicists i didn't really learn it in
undergrad i came across diasporities
later
but just a basic look at the literature
supports what mcgovern has been testing
which is the fact that wine was
routinely mixed with different compounds
it's fascinating by the way that
language affects our
conception
of the tools we use to understand the
world so like
like it you can see wine
you can see psychedelics
if they're not
called drugs
you you can uh
you can maybe reframe
how you see them in terms of their role
in on us thinking about the world
understanding the world that's really
interesting that language has that power
but what language was used to understand
wine at the time
so we're talking about a greek speaking
world right so you know jesus
uh is born and does his public ministry
in the holy land but think about the
early church think about where the
church takes root you know paul the
greatest evangelist of the time writes
basically half the new testament he's
writing letters in greek to greek
speakers in places like corinth
in greece
or philippi
a defunct city just north of the island
of thassos or he's writing to folks in
what today is is turkey
the colossians the galatians he writes
letters to the romans
these are greek speakers in these
pockets these hellenic pockets all
around the ancient mediterranean and for
them again
ignore discordies ignore pat mcgovern's
work to them to think about wine was to
think about a mixed a mixed potion and
so the word oinos in ancient greek does
show up in the new testament but there
was another word to describe wine and it
exists for like a thousand years before
during and after the life of jesus the
word used for wine is farmacon which
obviously gives us the word pharmacy it
means drug
so in greek a greek speaker would
actually use the word drug
to refer to wine ruth skodal the
classicist talks about this as a as a
ritualistic formula
they understood wine
as this compound beverage a drug against
grief
a medicinal elixir
that could either harm or heal or just
maybe a sacrament to put you in touch
with wine gods old and new
clearly
religion
and myth but
religion very much so has
sort of uh
much like dreams has like an imagery
component like
you're kind of going outside
the
visual constraints of physical space
where you kind of have very specific
conceptions of what
things look like and you kind of
use your imagination to
stretch beyond the world as we know it
things that are
try to get in touch with things that are
more real than real
what role do these tools
do these
uh farmicons
have in trying to stimulate the imagery
of religion like do you have a sense
that they have a critical role here or
is this just a bunch of different
factors
that are utilized a bunch of different
tools that are utilized to construct
this imagery or is this not even or is
imagery the wrong terminology is it more
like space of ideas that's core to to
religion no i think the wine is
absolutely essential and so if it's
impossible to understand paleo
christianity in the absence of ancient
greek i think it's equally difficult in
the absence of
the sacred pharmacopoeia or wine itself
right just just think about wine
at the time um i i think that the
ancient greek audience would have heard
that
in a very different way um from us and
so they're referring to it maybe as a
pharmacon but the followers of dionysus
which precedes jesus and in some cases
the story of jesus is kind of a
recapitulation of the mysteries of
dionysus but when you think about
dionysus
maybe from your high school mythology
you think about him as the god of
theater or the god of wine which is
typically what it is or the god of
ecstasy um you know again dionysus is
not the god of alcohol there's no
concept
of of fermented grapes the power of
dionysus and the ability to commune with
dionysus through his blood
and before christianity the blood
of dionysus is equated to his wine the
sacramental drinking of the wine was
interpreted and classicist write about
this including walter berkert
it was interpreted as consuming the god
himself in order to become one with the
god this is where we get the idea of
enthusiasm because the language matters
enthusiasm to be filled with the spirit
of the god so that you became identified
with dionysus and acquired his divine
powers now how does that happen
again he's not the god of alcohol he is
the god of wine but he's really the god
of madness and delirium
and frenzy and his principal followers
are women they're called the mine ads
and the way they get in touch with him
is through the consumption of the
sacramental wine
even at the theater of dionysus
separate from his outdoor churches there
was a wine served there called drima
and this is the wine that gives birth to
hollywood i mean the ancient hollywood
was there at the theater of dionysus
this is where comedy and tragedy and
poetry and music come from
but rather than a hot dog and a beer
what they drink at the theater of
dionysus
was this wine called trima which means
pounded or rubbed and professor ruck
talks about maybe it was the drugs that
were rubbed into this theatrical
beverage
to help the uh play come alive so
madness is seen as a positive thing is
it like a creative journey
it's not it's not uh
it's it's the what is it the unlearning
getting out of the way kind of thing
is is that how it seemed or is it more
like um
entertaining escape
from life that is suffering
i gotta i gotta inject a little modern
dostoevsky into the old
existential despair um maybe it's maybe
it's a bit of that
we we can't say that there wasn't
recreational drinking happening um the
greeks also had the symposium right
um and they also were just getting
hammered in some cases yeah but when it
comes to the rights of dionysus yeah
what you see there is um
the creation
of these states of awareness in which
again you identify with the god to
become the god there's there's theophagy
there's the consumption of divinity in
order to become divinity right back to
how we started the conversation right so
if we stop conceiving of god as
something exterior to us but that the
mystery
of being itself is the mystery of your
being and the mystery of my being that
the way to encounter that is through the
sacramental theology that you drink
the actual blood of this greek god to
become
that god and there was a place for this
in ancient greek society so drinking the
wine is drinking the blood of dionysus
do you think jesus
is
an actual physical person that existed
in history or is he an idea
that
came to
to life through the consumption of wine
and those kinds of rituals
so this is where i faced my ex
communication depending how i answer
this
[Laughter]
i mean you're you're playing with fire
and wine
[Laughter]
a good combination by the way yeah
uh so
i i shy away from that controversy in
the book i'm perfectly willing to accept
jesus as a historical personage um you
know we have the multiplicity of sources
although it's a generation after his
death um but we have the eucharist being
described in the four gospels we have it
being described by paul
in first corinthians
but when you read john it does read a
bit differently than the other gospels
and in my book i rely a lot on the
scholarship of dennis mcdonald who
writes a fabulous book called the
dionysian gospel
and this is again why the greek matters
because once you start to analyze the
greek of john's gospel
it seems to be a presentation of jesus
very much in the guise of dionysus the
most obvious example is the wedding at
cana right
that only occurs in john's gospel the
famous transformation of water into wine
now again to any greek speaker of the
first century they would have known
about the greek district of ellis on the
peloponnese and in ellis around the
epiphany every january the priests of
dionysus would deposit these water
basins empty basins in the temple of
dionysus they'd return the next morning
and find them magically filled with wine
now on the island of andros it's even
more interesting around the same
epiphany date the gods gift day dies
theodosia the wine would emanate from
the temple and run like a river
for a week and you can google the
bachanal of the andreans a wonderful
painting by titian which hangs in the
prado and you'll see a river of wine
behind these people having a great time
this exists for centuries and centuries
before the wedding at cana and before
jesus begins his public ministry with
what these scholars call the signature
miracle of dionysus it would not have
been lost on the greek audience that
that something very specific is being
communicated here what's being
communicated that you just might find in
early christianity
what you hold strong to in these
mysteries of dionysus that you may have
inherited from your parents your
grandparents your great-grandparents for
centuries there was a perfectly good
religion there were perfectly good
mystery cults in the ancient greek and
roman worlds and here comes this new
untested illegal cult
illegal of a dozen or so illiterate day
laborers that go on to convert the
empire in a few hundred years
the answer to that
extraordinary growth is not psychedelics
but i do think it's visionary
experiences and i do think it's this
continuity from the pagan world into
early christianity
you